this is a cultural revolution it yeah it
is and they're going to extirpate Trump
from public life as much as they can
they're going to take everything from
him as much as they can and anyone who
stands in Alliance with him I mean Rudy
Giuliani for me is crazy the fact that
you know he's got a mugshot too that
that wasn't that was America's mail
wasn't it he's the greatest yeah he was
he was the guy at 9 11.
he's he's the guy who ridded New York of
crime right like it's before 9 11 he
cleaned up the city amazingly well right
he got rid of the mobs and stuff right
and it's really Junior can essentially
be paraded around in Chains like the
failed opposition in a Roman civil war
with Donald Trump and everyone else
around him I mean what kind of country
failed Roman Civil War tell me more well
I mean well okay
in a Roman Civil War basically the uh
the losing party get killed